hello everyone so I'm going to be
telling you about strange loops or
capturing knots with powerful notations
first off
photos are okay because knots are hard
to draw and that's one of the main
points of my talk so this is the hook we
had this quote from mathematician John
Conroy who says widow tells us that the
numeration of the fifty-four knots of
six took him six years the notation we
and you know us we shall soon describe
may this just one afternoon's work how
did we how did he do this well here's
how we're going to get there we're going
to start off with a crash course in knot
theory then we'll talk about Alexander
Briggs notation which is sort of a
simple bad notation go into dr. notation
which augments it talked about
numeration briefly and then finally
answer the question by going through
connor notation and then we'll talk
about modern populations the question
you should have in mind here is which of
these notations to modern up theorists
actually use and then finally lessons
that may or may not be related to
programming languages so what is a not
firstly I want to give some credit to
this book which I bought a lot of intro
material from so our impression of a
knot is you know sort of you have a
length of string and then you you know
tie it like a normal shoelace knot like
this right but mathematicians do one
thing and that's they join the ends like
this or on the slide so and not speak
they've embedded a line in two or three
and one thing the mathematicians can do
that we can't do is have a stretch do
not so you might start with ah you might
start with the thing over there and you
can sort of move it around and move the
orange thing down and move the other leg
over and then you end up with this knot
which is exactly the same well exactly
for some definition called the trefoil
when we talk about knots we usually talk
about them in terms of crossings so
crossing is just one strand over the
other the simplest knot is the knot it's
just a circle and a more complicated
type of knot which we don't consider or
not is a link which is multiple
so this is like a Venn diagram those are
the Olympic rings so now that you've
seen all these nuts how do we actually
tell them apart well we have this sort
of basic definition of equivalence where
we have three different moves that can
do to a string and there they all
preserve equivalents so first one
straight string twist it over or untwist
convince yourself this is the same thing
second one you sort of take two strings
and move one over the other it doesn't
change anything
third one you have a crossing and you
remove a string over under it doesn't
change anything so you might be
wondering well these two knots that I've
just seen how do we know they're not
actually the same knot maybe there's
some way we can maneuver this thing in
order to make it into a simple circle
and you have to take my word for the
fact that the answer is no but you know
it can look it up later so let's talk
about Alexander Briggs notation first
knots are very complicated the ones
you've seen are pretty simple and
they're very visual so they're visually
gives rise to the following pretty hard
problem as Conroy said one thing I never
figured out was how do I tell a knot to
a nerd over the phone keep in mind that
the person you're talking to it's just
as much of a nerd as you are you know so
the person sitting next to you it's
strange aloof how you're going to tell
them that not so we're going to pick one
particular example called the stevedore
not it's one that sailors used to tie
ropes to stop them from slipping so
those of you in the audience were
interested in nautical things right like
this okay it's a knot theory talk there
has to be a knot plan so here's our sort
of mental model of the thing that's the
stevedore knot with the ends closed and
we want to transmit that over the phone
to someone else who's going to try and
draw or write down the exact same knot
and you know if you mess up they're
gonna be angry so think about the person
next to you they're gonna be angry if
you mess this up so the most trivial
thing to do is well you know we have
this knot and we think about knots in
terms of crossings so let's count the
number of crossings I send out over the
wire you know
one analogy might be taking an object
and serializing it into text and then
the other person DC realizes that not or
that text into an object but how
effective is this notation well I mean
you get a six what do you do with that
six it could be either of these knots
take my word for the fact that they are
different and not the state or not what
you can prove so this notation has a
really big problem and that is it
compresses the not too much right there
way too much information and now we
cannot reconstruct it so let's try and
augment that by talking about darker
notation so starting with this not again
how we're going to augment the number of
crossings well the most obvious thing to
do is sort of talk about specific
crossings and add directions on top of
them so okay let's arbitrarily pick this
crossing and start going around this way
and now we're going to travel along the
knot on that strand so for the first
Crossing is labeled one we go around the
next one is labeled to go around three
four five six you know just traveling
around and we finished decorating the
knot so by now it looks like a Christmas
tree with a bunch of baubles and we've
got numbers and all the crossings let's
write all the numbers down so notice
that there are six crossings so there
are 12 numbers because every crossing
gets passed through twice because
there's an over strand and an understand
in addition every crossing gets an odd
and an even number you should convince
yourself about this it's an exercise for
the reader so okay the thing is we have
a lot of redundant information here that
we can throw away without any loss of
fidelity and that is the fact that every
crossing gets passed through twice so
throw away half of them just keep the
ones with odd numbers at the top and
sort them this is our new notation still
there is some redundant information we
can throw away the odd numbers at the
top and how that as a protocol will
always have the first and odd numbers on
the top where n is the number of
crossings so a final notation is our
name for the knot in doctor notation
which is 8 6 10 to 12 4 which is you
know not a very thoroughly name but
that's the name notice one thing
this knot wasn't alternating not meaning
that as you travel around it you go over
straw and then under over and so on so
dr. notation can encode non alternating
knots it's pretty simple I just won't
talk about it okay so we're going to
send that over the wire here's our tin
can phone and we're thinking about the
stevedore knot and we're saying the
sequence of texts and sending it to that
person and they're like okay so now what
do I do
first I want us to think about sort of
correspondences between knots and
notations how many different notations
could you have sent over so when we
started with this we could have made
many choices we could have picked any of
the crossings to start from we could
have picked the over strand or the under
strut and start from we could have gone
forward or backwards so that gives you
about four n different notations for the
same knot and that's one thing that
person on the run has to keep in mind
here's a more general diagram what we
really want is this green one a
projection a one to one correspondence
between object and notation that's the
goal but unfortunately it doesn't exist
or not unless you can invent one no
that's really pretty cool so what we
have here is you know a slightly worse
scenario which is that one dot can
correspond to multiple notations we just
saw this we might have the case where
one notation can correspond to multiple
nuts
we will see this and we might have cases
where a notation corresponds to nothing
we will see this too we will see cases
where a knot will not have any notation
which is also a problem yes and not or
not so back to the person on the right
they got your transmission what are they
going to do with it it's actually sort
of a hard puzzle because they have to
reverse-engineer the entire process you
went through traveling around the
strands so let's start are not named
eight six ten to twelve four forget you
oversaw the original diagram we first
put the first end odd numbers back on
top okay cool
now we're going to sort of go backwards
and start with oh the first crossing was
one by definition and the next crossing
was two
and how the southern attached to it and
the next crossing miss three just
because that's the order we traveled
through it on so we're going to do that
so the first crossing one a to seven and
so on and I drew it twice because there
are going to be two possibilities later
so that's the first part and eventually
you'll hit a point where after you've
done the fifth crossing what the sixth
crossing is a paired number that's
already there so now you're going to
loop back onto this sort of bridge spine
thing that you drew but here we could
have gone around either way so that's
already a difference in diagrams and
just keeping on with the drawing when
you do the other crossings they're also
going to be more multiple ways and this
you know is a problem with dr. notation
in general and those two are not
drawable so I'm not going to go into the
details of why but there are ways to
sort of trap yourself inside a diagram
and sometimes you might need to add a
new crossing that's not on the spline so
okay great we've finished drawing the
two knots but you know which is this
gasps are they even the same thing we
sort of the same rotation should they be
the same knot and are they even the
stevedore not that we wanted in the
first place so that's our problem
does anyone see if they're the same knot
yeah so you can just sort of move the
top to the bottom and convince yourself
they're the same thing so we'll just
talk about the red one the most
important question so it did we
successfully transmitted this thing
we're going to cheat a little and start
with the decorated not we had but in
general we could just sort of write out
always and test that so we're going to
correct a mistake I made in the drawing
and then rotate the knot 180 degrees
which does not change the not at all so
we're going to try and match up this one
eight with that one eight so this
traveling around the one it is an over
strand that's an over strong that's very
promising so let's try and correspond
the two knots with blue okay that's
pretty good you can sort of see the
strange loop starting to form green one
okay yeah this
looks pretty good that next loop and
finally okay so I think there they are
the same knot but this you know was a
visual proof and was not very rigorous
and in general when he drawn out they're
going to end up in this weird form and
you know you're gonna have to do some
work to figure out if they're really the
same knot poor thing so this notation
gave us something really important that
we might not have realized in the first
place and that is every single knot has
a doubt your notation and what is that
bias well if we write out every single
attacker notation then we will have
enumerated every single knot inside that
list so all knots our slopes of all
darker notations but there might be some
jump that we have to throw out and we'll
see how that happens so let's talk about
how to actually enumerate knots with
daggers recall that are not notation was
just a bunch of even numbers in some
permutation that were consecutive so
because this is a programming conference
here is one slide of code where we
enumerate daggers and you know it's
pretty algorithmic and easy this is
written in Haskell so darker is one
meaning all the knots with darker
notation with one crossing it's one two
and you know there we get that knot
which is strange loop 2015 whoo
unfortunately this is not actually a
knot because it can untwist it in two
and unknot and it's not really what
we're looking for so that's our first
hint that enumeration might be harder
than we thought
next we have all dampers with two
crossings and you know that's great but
each one of them can have their ends
untwisted and they both turn into a knot
so more trash though you have to throw
up and then all Dockers are three
crossings
well how many knots do you think are
actually inside that list yeah so
there's exactly one knot with three
crossings and it's mirror image which
we'll ignore and that's the truth well
we just saw that's the correct one a
couple of the notations for respond to
the same trefoil but you know just
starting out a different crossing and
some of them are just plain old or not
so one thing we can do with darker
notation to check your colons is we can
find something of this form inside a
knot and untwist it because when you go
through the strand you're gonna give it
number N and then when you go back
you're going to give an M plus one so if
you see an attempt list one paired it
you can always be like oh well
always on twisters so let's just ignore
it that's one way to check your code
once there are a lot of other heuristics
so now that we've gotten a sure intro to
enumeration with Talcher let's talk
about the history because we didn't
invent this in isolation there's a lot
of very interesting prior work in fact
the prior work goes back as far as 1870
wire Lord Kelvin thought well I think
atoms are vortices in the luminiferous
ether that's how they've talked back
then so if we read out all these
vortices which are not then we will have
a periodic table of all the elements so
kelvins like well teh teh is a
physicists of the time do you think that
thing is possibly one and today is like
yeah I'm right on this I'm gonna newer
all the knots and find the periodic
table and make myself famous but you
know as we found out in 1900 rather for
it was like I'm pretty sure atoms are
not knots they're like electrons and
stuff so fine but not theorists carry
the torch forward so this is what a
table actually looks like this is from
Wikipedia
notice that our good friend the stupid
or not is hanging out over here and one
thing that enumeration can do for us is
Nick Alexander Briggs notation work
circled in green because once we have
tables we can just say oh hey friend
next to me who I'm talking to over the
phone for some reason I want to tell you
about the first knot with six crossings
in my knot table and because I have a
table with some arbitrary order we can
just do this so that's what one thing
tables can do for us another great thing
according to a knot theorists we hope
that the census which they did have
knots they call it a census will serve
as a rich source of examples on counter
examples and as a general testing ground
for
intuition this is really useful because
sometimes you'll have theorems that seem
true and are true for the first 100,000
knots and then on the thousandth knot
with 15 crossings your theorem will be
wrong and it's really great to have a
table to just check that on so our
general energy for enumeration is going
to be the same as we did here we're
going to write out all the notations
enumerate that textually and then grip
the notes that are actually equivalent
and then throw out some random trash
that stuck in there there are a couple
of schools of notation dapper is just
one of them Alexander Briggs isn't even
a school that doesn't care so we have
one school that breaks down the knot
which we just talked about
it started with Gillis yes that girl's
in 1800 who you know run around they're
not the same way the physicists we just
talked about and doctor himself the next
school builds up the knot it is a
totally different approach it doesn't
take a knot and give you the number it
sort of defines these irreducible
prudence that combine in ways to form
knots and this school includes Kirk
grant from the 1880s Conway himself and
he'll drone a contemporary so let's go
into conversation and try to find out
the answer to this question why is his
notation so much more efficient we saw
that docker wasn't that efficient
because checking equivalence is really
hard and sort of arbitrary and we need
heuristics so here are the primitives
we're going to talk about we have twists
which you get by just taking two strings
and twisting them like this fine then we
have tangles which combine twists and
tangles in some way and then we have
knots which do something to tangles to
turn them into a loop and not just
strings in a circle here is what some
tangles in the wild look like again I
want to acknowledge the nut book for a
very good intro material so here is an
abstract picture of a jingle
now this stuff is going to be seem very
sort of technical and arbitrary but
we'll see why they were defined in a
food slot
so a tingle is just a circle with two
strings in it twisted in some way there
are four corners the Northwest North is
Southwest southeast corners here are two
of the simplest channels every tangle
starts with these and gets built up so
we have the zero tangle which is you
know two strings with the endpoints at
the corners or the Infinity tangle which
is the other way so the zero tangle we
can make the one tangle just by twisting
it upward once so the bottom strand
comes to the top and it's over the other
strand and the three tangle you just
twist it through time it's also the same
as 1 plus 1 plus 1
what is 1 plus 1 the way we defined
tangle addition is very pretty very
simple so we have these two tangles and
we just connect their northeast
endpoints and the northwest ones same
for the southern ones so that's 2 1 plus
t2 here is a slightly more complicated
operation we have two tangos t1 and t2
and we want to multiply them first we're
going to flip the first tangle over the
Northwest through southeast I know so
just like this and then after they're
flipped we're just at them we've talked
about addition everybody so when you see
a 2 1 x 2 2 or we might get rid of the
multiplication symbol
you should think flip then add that's
all that is how do we make these tangles
into knots what we do is we have this
thing called the 1 star polyhedra which
is basically just saying okay you have a
tangle now just plug it in here and
connect the endpoints for example we
have the two one tangle to turn that
into a knot which the tangle is the
thing in the circle the knot is the
entire thing we just plug it in and
that's the final result so yes sort of
technical weird and arbitrary yes I know
there is sort of a deep reason why we
defined these in this way so let's go
through an example
let's try to construct the tangle called
3 2 negative 4 so as we said just start
with three by twisting it three times
now we're going to try and make three
times two because this notation is left
associative okay so we're going to do
three times two when you see
multiplication I think flip the net so
flip then add okay great that's the
three times two one now that one's done
it's left associative let's do the three
times two times negative four tangle
think flip then add so flip add so
that's the entire thing pronounce 3 2
negative 4 3 times 2 times negative 4
and we make into a nut by simply putting
it into the polyhedron so when you draw
it a little better we end up with this
beautiful not 3 to negative 4 it's very
happy to be here and see you all so if
we get rid of the multiplication
operation and just think about what
we're doing abstractly what we're doing
is making or not we're starting with
these two strings and then twisting any
two adjacent endpoints like say twist
the bottom and then twist these two and
then twist the top and so on so you can
swap the top ones right ones bottom ones
or left ones
that's multiplication that's what it's
doing so you can reverse it so any a
tango constructed in this way can be
untangled by just swapping adjacent
endpoints okay it still seems a little
bit weird an arbitrary why do we care
about this well this is a picture of DNA
it's tangled in a very tingly sort of
way
so these tangles actually describe the
topology of DNA in the wild very well
because as it turns out the only way
that nature can really tangle things is
by swapping adjacent endpoints and and
so like this well you might be thinking
well but maybe every tangle can be
untangled and tangled by just swapping
adjacent endpoints like is there
anything more complicated and actually
there's a simple counter example to that
so the ones we talked about our rational
tangles there are the easy ones the
harder ones are these
it's called algebraic angles this is
just the three plus three angle and
convince yourself that this can't be
untangled just by swapping adjacent
endpoints okay so let's move into the
same thing we've been trying to do all
along which is how are we going to
transmit this not over the phone pretend
the convoy is trying to sell this to you
and you're receiving it from him so he's
thinking he's thinking about the stupid
or not and you know how would you do is
try and identify the tingles in this and
how you'd build up the not so que con
with God idea he's gonna rotate or not
good job fun way and he thinks oh look
at these two circles they look like
circles with strings in the corners and
those look a lot like tingles made by
twisting in fact that looks just like
the floor to not so Conway is very happy
and he is going to send this over to you
now euro are going to receive it and be
very happy because there's a very well
defined algorithm to Jali's knots which
we just talked about but in general it's
easy for you on your own to receive the
knot it was hard for it will be hard for
Conway in general because we have you
know these more complicated knots that
are not so easy to decompose them to
tangles they require a non-trivial
amount of manipulation in swapping and
there actually exist knots which don't
have a Conway notation so you might be
thinking well but then we can't use it
for enumeration at all why are we even
talking about this we should throw it
out that's true not that we should throw
it out but we should really seriously
doubt whether we should use this it
turns out that because his notation
encodes these sort of deep intuitions
about knots
most of the small knots are rational so
we can still do this so let's talk about
how to enumerate knots with comma
so say we want to enumerate all knots of
three crossings how are we going to
write out all the tingly things that
will numerate these knots
well so consider the one tangle you
twisted it once so you added one
crossing say the number of crossings in
a tangle is absolute value of T then
every operation adds the number of
crossings so for example when you
multiply t1 and t2 the number of
crossings in them is the sum of the
number of crossings in each individual
one so we want to sort of work backwards
from this adding and decompose a number
into multiple numbers there is a
mathematical word for this you are
partitioning the number so here's how
you partition three for example number
three it could be separated into three
groups of one or two groups of one thing
and then two things or two groups of two
things and then one things in general
they're not the same so we're going to
have both of them or just one group of
three things what have we just done this
is absolutely isomorphic to knots of
three crossings because now we have four
tangles with three crossings 1 1 1 1 2 2
1 3 and you all remember how to multiply
tingles and knots in order to get these
right so now that we have these
notations and we have a very nicely
algorithmic way to draw the diagram so
we can do something pretty incredible we
can just draw them all on a computer so
I wrote some code in Haskell to
decompose or partition numbers and then
just draw them and uses the diagrams
library which is fabulous so these are
all the raw nuts and links up to seven
crossings and you can see their
notations next to long ok but you want
to know the answer to the question how
is Conroy's notation more efficient than
other people's notation we talked about
how equivalence is not equivalent is an
open problem which people
solved yet so we're going to see how
Conway solved this problem by Oh
basically magic I mean nothing magic for
the same thing right so let's consider
these two tangles so why do we care
about Tengu equivalence well if a tangle
or not is composed of tangles and if all
the knots in the tangle are exactly the
same or equivalent by moving stuff
around then the knots are equivalent so
tangle equivalence implies not
equivalence so these two tingles have
different notations but they're the same
because what we can do is take that loop
over there rotate it out of the plane of
the page and end up with that one
so that was negative two two twisted two
times and the other two know they're to
twist this is to one twisted two times
or something with one twist so they're
equivalent and we're going to do
something that seems weird an arbitrary
again we're going to take these
notations and put them inside a
continued fraction backwards so two one
becomes the continued fraction one plus
one over and then in the next number
which is to which yields three halves
negative two two is going to be calm to
backwards plus one over the first number
negative 2/3 house it's the same wow
what an amazing weird arbitrary
coincidence has mathematics gone too far
what's going on here what is this one
weird trick to check my equivalence
Conway how did you do this
so in summary we're putting the tingles
notation just the numbers and text
backwards into a continued fraction this
will yield a rational number because all
the numbers are integers and we have the
theorem that rational tangos are
equivalent if and only if they
represented were the same rational
number why why well unfortunately I
can't give you the intuition of really
proof now because it's pretty long in a
bowl but you should look at the
footnotes the one problem with this is
that well you know Connor had solved
this for every single kind of
and most natural tickles and he's you
know just solved my equivalence the big
open problem right so he should have a
Fields Medal unfortunately this only
works for rational tangles the easier
ones that are you know made a nature
just by swapping adjacent endpoints
unfortunately the algebraic ones which
we saw earlier which can't be decomposed
by swapping adjacent ones well we're
gonna need some tricks and weird stuff
to get those to work
so these algebraic knots we already
talked about the one star polyhedra on
the top left we've been using them all
along but more complicated knots are
going to need these other polyhedra that
you're plugging tangles into in order to
solve the problem of well some not still
have economy notation so that's a little
problematic but it turns out again that
small knots meaning knots of seven
crossings or under are all irrational
knots so we can do this so the answer to
our question
how did Conway enumerate he has not so
much faster than Whittle did them he
proved very powerful theorems in about
special cases so I'm willing to bet that
what he did was him a human he took a
pencil and enumerated all of these knots
and then calculated each of their
continued fractions and throughout the
ones that he didn't want and he was able
to do this algorithmically without any
diagram chasing or whatever so he did
this in one afternoon but little who
used our notation
didn't have those powerful affordances
for small knots so he spent you know six
years pushing these strings around on
paper and trying to figure out which
ones were equivalent in basically a
joker notation so now all of you have
all the information needed to decide
whether modern out theorists use Conway
or dr. notation so who here thinks that
modern not theorists use dr. notation
raise your head
okay so a little less than half a lot
less than half actually and who here
thinks that they use Conway okay so
about 3/4 so we're going to talk about
this
absolutely marvelously titled paper
called the first 1 million 700 1936
knots if you ever needed a party fact
you have won all the knots of 16
crossings or less there are 1 million
700 1936 of them so again one notation
that they use well the answer is going
to be on the next slide so think hard
about what you answered maybe you want
to switch it so I was also curious about
lists and I emailed you know an actual
not theorist about this and here is what
he responded by email I find it
intriguing that the most successful
modern tabulations don't use all the
cleverness that can be found and instead
used other notation which is a much more
naive notation this is Dylan Thurston
who is a professor of topology so the
two or three of you who chose dr.
congratulations you're right why why did
they do this why didn't they do this one
as Dylan said Kaname found all this
cleverness so in this more closely
titled paper they compared contrast the
two notations dr. is very compact it
doesn't have Conway's complicated series
of protocols but again it's hard to
manipulate but Conway's is worse for
very big knots why well as host says
host is the author of this paper Conroy
scheme draws on a large set of symbols
which you saw arranged according to a
rather large set of rules which seem
arbitrary at times both of which grow
with cross number which is bad because
when we enumerate knots we want to
increase the crossing number more and
more up to 16 or 20 and for this reason
it does not lend itself well to computer
programming this is a pretty significant
problem the thing is well you might be
thinking well why even talk about Conway
he invented this thing what nobody is
using it so what it's just a detour in
the history of
it turns out that the insights encoded
in his notation actually helped him
discover a new algebraic and variant
which I'm not going to talk about but
this basically opened up a new field of
sub a subfield of knot theory because
algebraic invariants are sort of hard to
come by and he invented a new one so
what are some takeaways we can get from
you know a tale of two notations we have
several axes against which to contrast
and compare any notation you want to
talk about first do they break down
objects or build them up so you know
think about your favorite serialization
protocol or something how easy is it for
humans to read and write how easy is it
for machines to read and write is it
minimal are there a lot of rules too
they grow the crossing number and
finally how do notations correspond to
objects this diagram again we're not can
be replaced with objects do we have you
know the mother lode a by junction
between notation and object which would
mean we had somehow perfectly captured
the essence of the object in text or do
we have some problems does one object
correspond to multiple notations as one
notation corresponds most objects are
there invalid notations or objects some
more significant axes how easy is it to
read important insights off of this
notation how legible is it what kinds of
insights does it encode did you prove
some powerful theorems that helped you
how easy is it just to do common
operations on this notation for your
object maybe on common operations can be
harder and most importantly what new
manipulations and ways of thinking
does your notation encourage so now for
so improve my language lessons so say we
can't think about this correspondence so
programs are sort of like a blob in your
head that's you know vaguely like a knot
so this person is thinking about maybe
the identity function as a blob their
head some sort of essence and that
corresponds to the knot we can say that
a programming language of course
spawns to a notation for that not so an
object in that language a program
corresponds to a notation for that
particular not there's also an
interesting correspondence between
program equivalence and not equivalence
both are hard problems program
equivalence has been proven undecidable
not equivalence again is an open problem
so it hasn't been proven hard but it
seems pretty hard and in both cases we
want to just look at the syntax or the
notation of the object and figure out
are there essence is the same
are they the same in summary don't get
too attached to one notation of
representation there can be something
really useful unexpected or
interdisciplinary just waiting for you
to just go over to invent it actually
that's not the real takeaway the real
takeaway is this movie poster for
Conroy's notation so like not a book
written by not theorist music as
powerful host reviews it actually as
deep structure properties of knots for
stars so there's a lot of stuff i
alighted in this talk you should consult
these sources in particular I read at
least for undergraduate honors theses to
get a lot of the material because not
there is accessible that people with not
a lot of prior background so I read like
for thesis I'm seniors in college they
were very good and I really want to
thank the people who helped me with this
talk David Brenner who helped me an
unbelievable amount even take him enough
Rose Ames who was in the audience and
listened to a practice talk at 6 a.m.
today thank you so much Dylan Thurston a
bonafide not theorists who humor this
programming language researcher who got
interested in nuts
Williams Keith who gave great feedback
by email Leonard behringer one of my
advisors who listened to a cactus
talking to white board and finally the
recurse Center for having awesome people
who encouraged me to submit this talk
and get feedback on it so if you want
the code for not drawing or whatever
other code it had you should look at
this repo right now it's not for a
public consumption but it will be in a
few days and you can ask me questions on
Twitter thanks
you